that gavin williamson the education
secretary is leaving that post he's just
tweeted it's been a privilege to serve
as education secretary since 2019.
despite the challenges of the global
pandemic i'm particularly proud of the
transformational reforms i've led in
post-16 education in further education
colleges our skills agenda
apprenticeships and more this programme
will create better life opportunities
for pupils and students for many years
to come i look forward to continuing to
support the prime minister and the
government now that's a really
interesting one because that tweet
sounds to me that he's out like he's out
completely and what we were saying
before and this has come from a number
of different sources again unconfirmed
is that the prime minister may well be
making moves here to actually just
completely remove some of his most
senior ministers by taking them out of
the cabinet altogether now that tweet
really does read like somebody who
perhaps has seen the writing on the wall
maybe even made the decision themselves
to leave before the prime minister asks
them to
and this is one of the things that
happens in reshuffles because the prime
minister may want to move people in his
team and sam said it just before you
can't guarantee that people will accept
a demotion or a move to a different
department and then you don't know what
they're going to be like when they're on
your back benches you know that's a real
danger for a prime minister yes he has a
large majority but over the last couple
of weeks there's been some pretty
controversial things pushed through
parliament very quickly social care is
one of them yes the rebellion from the
conservative back benches was smaller
and meant that the bill could still go
through but any rebellion for a prime
minister is difficult and the more of
those things that happen and the more
people on your benches who feel
disgruntled and frustrated and feel like
they don't owe the prime minister
anything well that becomes really
difficult to govern so the prime
minister will have to watch out for that
as we say you know we don't we don't
know whether gavin williamson has been
offered another job or whether he would
even accept one if he had been offered
one i think it's fair to say that we've
not seen him go into the house of
commons nobody's noted his car go in
although we did hear on confirmed
reports that he'd given a leaving speech
to his department pretty early on after
it was announced the reshuffle was
happening to